a mi izquierda la diseñadora de moda
marín ser a mi derecha a la cantautora
george smith
[Música]
también estaba lista para la sesión de
fotos la cantante lourdes maría ciccone
león conocida como lola la hija de
madonna estamos a pocos minutos del
inicio del desfile y la atención va en
aumento en un ambiente tranquilo marín
set de 30 años es la líder de una nueva
generación de diseñadores de moda
comprometidos para la presentación de su
colección de moda masculina verano 2023
juega con la inclusión y la diversidad a
todos los niveles por ejemplo no sólo
invitó a compradores influencers o
periodistas
este fue el primer desfile abierto al
público
así que invitamos a unas 1000 personas
de nuestra comunidad a través de
instagram
acabamos de hacer un llamado ya pueden
venir y también es estupendo para mí
poder invitar a la gente que quiera
venir un espectáculo y que no esté
reservado sólo a la gente que trabaja en
el mundo de la moda mil cupos gratis
si es gratis y tampoco tiene costo para
la noche
así que vamos a divertirnos y también
creo que lo importante es el vínculo con
lo que hago
también es que mi objetivo de sacar el
súper reciclaje a la calle y por lo
tanto necesariamente dar acceso al
espectáculo
de hecho se trata de cambiar este
sistema tanto nuestra forma de consumir
como la de vivir y el sistema de la moda
como se traduce esto en la ropa todo es
supra reciclaje
incluso las cosas nuevas están hechas
con hilo reciclado y lo que no ha pasado
por el proceso químico de nuevo que no
ha sido re procesado pero había tomado
cada hilo con su dolor y ha hecho algo
con él
y con esta técnica de supra reciclaje
nos muestra la alta costura
tiene un verdadero estilo son prendas
que no se pueden encontrar en ningún
otro sitio no son parches son realmente
artesanales
todos los estilos que se ven en aran
azul rosa con algún tipo de estampado
negro gm nuevo
todos esos eran toallas que escogí amos
y convertiremos en ropa
así que cuando hace calor como en este
caso uno puede limpiarse con una esponja
es práctico también habían pañuelos de
seda para todos los vestidos al final
también se reciclaron todos los blue
lines son viejos que ya no se usa que
recuperamos para hacer para que los
nuevos así que la idea es recuperar y
regenerar tomar lo que hay y
transformarlo y utilizar la creatividad
que tenemos para cambiar el mundo de
mañana en la pista de atletismo es una
especie de desfile preolímpico modelos
actrices deportistas levantadores de
pesas el atleta de paratriatlón alexis
yang qin gang estrellas como joy star y
la estrella de fútbol djibril cissé
eso también vale la pena mencionarlo
estaban todas las razas es realmente
fuerte lo que hizo e innovador porque
dar la vuelta a una pista así no sé si
se ha hecho alguna vez bueno al menos yo
nunca lo he visto y francamente me quito
el sombrero
la agencia hide es una mujer poderosa es
una mujer moderna y creo que toda mujer
debería abrazar su poder como ella me
encanta
marín
porque es tan poderosa
no tiene miedo de perseguir sus sueños y
de involucrar a todos sus amigos y
familiares esta es una cualidad de las
mujeres que la gente se mantiene unida
pero que también está en su poder
así es martín
valencia hace emuladores tras pasar por
la escuela tú pues el instituto francés
de la moda y balenziaga gym y field
puede por fin presentar su colección por
primera vez que pretende ser no binaria
cuestiona los criterios de masculinidad
y feminidad sí
creo sobre todo que se trata de palabras
antiguas que ya no tienen ningún
simbolismo real hoy en día o que hay que
deconstruir y que se puede ser un hombre
femenino o una mujer masculina y que
esto no es necesariamente un problema es
más bien una ventaja cuáles son sus
mayores retos en la actualidad yo diría
que ya tuvimos la oportunidad de mostrar
nuestra tercera colección que es una
primicia con el público tener un
verdadero evento ser apoyados por la
federación francesa de plata para usted
así que nuestras dificultades yo diría
que la gente sea receptiva a una moda
sin género tener una moda ética con
cantidades limitadas las dificultades
son ser mujer en la moda y tener
visibilidad eso es todo
en cuanto a las ventas tanto las tiendas
grandes como las pequeñas y las redes de
distribución siguen siendo reacias a dar
espacio a las colecciones unisex
mi mensaje es una moda no específica de
género la moda para todos personas lgtb
para que todos puedan encontrar una
pieza en jean frío enamorarse del
material del corte y sentirse bien
y construir nuevos imaginarios responder
a las emergencias climáticas y sociales
la moda de hoy en día ofrece respuestas
hermosas y deseables